hoarding may have a bad reputation but
what if it's cold hard cash with rising
employment more Americans are earning a
steady paycheck but much of that money
is going both unspent and uninvested
leaving banks brimming with cash to help
explain the new trend we are joined by
farnoosh Torabi host of the
award-winning podcast so money and
financial columnist for Oh The Oprah
Magazine good morning morning so what is
behind this new type of hoarding which
seems a little less severe and worse at
least on your house right I mean it's
also been a good thing people are saving
more and I think what's fueling it is
that we are uncertain about what's to
come
if you look at the healthcare scenario
which is sometimes for people their
biggest cost will out of their budget
we don't know where costs are going and
so we're not gonna go out and buy
sweaters and cars because we don't know
what's gonna happen there you look at
the stock market and you know the Dow is
up 60% since 2012 and some people are
thinking how much higher can this go and
then you're remembering the Great
Recession you know things got really
good before they got really bad yeah
it's interesting because I mean my
father grew up in the depression and
never he actually never let go with that
it affected almost every financial
decision he made for the rest of his
life having been through that how much
do you think the recession is is gonna
play in the people psychology going
forward I mean I think that we're human
beings at the end of the day it's hard
sometimes to something that happened 10
years ago may not be sort of friend of
mine right now but people who lost their
homes lost their job certainly that has
lasting impact emotional impact and so
we make decisions emotionally and so I
do think that has a lot to do with it so
what are the options I've looked at
savings accounts recently you're still
getting nothing but it's a little bit
better what can you do so I think it's
important to have a strategy if you have
more than enough in savings meaning you
have enough to cover you for an
emergency count for six to nine months
that should go you have more money than
that should go in other buckets so you
know there's online savings accounts
which are great for an emergency you can
get about a 1 to 1 and a quarter percent
yield which is better than a traditional
brick-and-mortar then if you have extra
money left over look at places like CDs
money market accounts money that you
don't need right away good for those
types of accounts and then look at
investing only 50% of Americans are
invest
and you know retirement is a real thing
and you're going to need money for it so
look at things like your 401k at work an
IRA and even a brokerage account a lot
of people still scared of the market
though after the way things went in the
recession understandably but you know my
approach is just a long-term strategy
you don't look at it as a day trading
kind of thing you know you're looking to
hopefully retire down the road 20 or 30
years from now loafie index funds ETFs
are safe and affordable way to go isn't
this idea though that people are not
spending that they're just saving this
cash isn't this ultimately bad for the
economy you know in the short term
perhaps we're gonna see some retail
sales suffer but I think that ultimately
this has to happen we have to go sort of
through a cleansing period and guess
what we're gonna be shopping again this
is just it's like already for news -
Robbie thanks so much that was this
morning